because I was just like too scared and
think about anything for Andrea Reda
surviving the mass shooting in Uvalde is
still a daily recurrence he just goes in
my mind just making Loops like the same
clip over and over again she was not
only at Robb Elementary that day but her
stepbrother 10 year old Jose Flores was
killed in the classroom next door I was
like excited to see him
it's still very was ready to hug him
and one more time he said he didn't make
it like then instead of crying again
I couldn't believe it happened
I was the middle child but I was more
braver than him so you're worried about
how scared he was that day yeah
like during the classroom I always
imagined him like how he like how his
face is and he's scared